hello everybody welcome back to let's
play cry for your okay oh man okay you
know what's up you know what's going on
I don't even need to explain it to you
guys you know what's going on
okay I don't need to sprint apparently
because not today just calmly walk away
Oh is right there that's okay though let
me try going down this way that's a dead
end
hello I'm over here oh that's what it
did why didn't they do it before I hit
it
you all saw I hit it oh I think I didn't
hit that one oh man okay what do I do
break this I don't have a I don't have a
break II thingy anymore
I don't have a melee weapon but there we
go that's what she did okay
please don't follow me guy don't follow
me guy guy
all right what's that take your lumps Oh
Alice that was the worst scare I've ever
had my life last episode if you didn't
see last episode see last episode
glad my FaceCam decided work for that
ooh boy
what a pretty view
[Music]
be lag and
like this
okay locked what's this gp7 the machine
missile or something
be yeah fairly powerful three-round
burst pistol
all right not like that it's a step in
the right direction
so haha here oh no no no this weapon
thup bulb ever I'll dump it for an
assault rifle later okay jump F bleep
I'm better now sorry for that
momentary lapse and toughness um ah you
son of a ja I'm crouched jumping I'm
jumping period you gotta be kidding I'm
out of jump juice
well gotta wait for it to recharge doo
doo doo ah gimmick up there you bastard
there we go I'm angry I get angry I get
mad
protip
ha there we go okay okay okay okay any
more epic job wait how to get over there
oh no I just I just boned myself dinner
okay angry look a bit tired I don't care
does this face look like it cares does
that okay whatever
EPIK don't get tired bro okay you want
your breath let me breathe you collected
I'm better now
sorry for that I'm all better okay going
that way I need to go this way at all
mmm-hmm all better
here we go nice just do that let's do
that every time okay
whoop there we go we go all hello buddy
what's that you want some all right we
loaded up I need some morphine in my
blood
[Music]
are you morphing like I need a needle in
the arm
haha hi Oh more jump okey good done with
the jumping who wants them anybody
okay not long not locked tired of
everything being locked I mean if people
are locking all their doors where is
everyone
besides Sophie who's dead all right
loading loading loading come on load
uh-oh oh no oh no to my game freeze you
didn't give me a save point after all
the jumping yep yep yep yep game froze
okay
I'll be back in a bit
I don't even know if my fraps is still
going but whatever hello everybody I'm
back um my game crashed in case the
video didn't I haven't checked the video
down I don't know where it left off I
don't know so mad
okay don't crash my game bro there we go
that's better
alright where the heck am I
all nice relaxing music this looks very
abandoned what's that
our deadlines weighing you wearing you
down the mod team hey oh here's a save
point you gotta be joking me after the
crash
my save was way back before you can beat
the chainsaw guy that made me mad I was
very upset very upset okay oh nice I
like it finally something inviting warm
cozy it's not gonna last
who's out there
well this looks positively dandy
everything's so nice everything so nice
I'm downright pleased dairying looks so
nuts
who's gonna ruin it computron skimmin
this is school school oh you gotta be
kidding me I'll go around teacher sorry
for trying to jump over the desk
screwdriver this P this this useless I
don't like I do not like it alright
that's that I got a screwdriver
well this one looks dark
Oh's in here oh these some people are
saving energy
oh no oh no oh no they made me come back
all this way just so they could torture
me but that's gonna have to wait until
the next one so thank you guys so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
markiplier Oh